وانا هيني هنا تحت القصف بشتغل هنا للبنات
وللاولاد ولبسهم من هالبرد القارص
هذا هذول اللي حوالي بيستنوا بدهم طواق وع
الدور واحد
[موسيقى]
ورا اسمي شهناز شفيق علي بكر عمري 64 سنه
تهجرنا من من غزه على رفع بجيب الفلينات
والله بعاني معانه لما اجيب لي فلينه ولا
علىشان اكرهم واعملهم فطين جرازي قواق
كلاكيل للاطفال الرمين ب يلبسوها هي
[موسيقى]
الخ يومي كله بعمل مع سته بكر صوف وبخليها
تعمل للبنات البنات حوالينا يعني جيراننا
بخليها تعمل لهم طواقي يعني انا بساعدها
عشان
اضلني كل يوم يعني هيك اقض وقتي عشان ما
زهقت هي العرب شايف العرب
[موسيقى]
الع نفسه اصلي بالمص
الاقصى نفسي اروح على المسجد الاقصى واصلي
في باحات
المك نفس الاحتلال ينتهي من
هانكون فلسطين حره ابيه من البحر الى
[موسيقى]
الهر